in the united kingdom so not in the
united states
a white civil servant is suing for
racial
and sexual discrimination this is in
london a white male civil servant
is filing a lawsuit matthew parr has a
salary
of 134 000 pounds per year
it's a very high salary right we're
talking this guy's making a lot of money
he also has a 7 900 pound living
allowance
wow man this guy how do i get that civil
service job but he's going to sue
because he learned that a black woman
went williams
was hired and makes significantly more
money an extra
50 000 pounds a year it seems she had
accepted a lower offer but then she was
just automatically given a higher offer
because the civil service was afraid
that she maybe she was being paid less
than someone else
so ordinarily we hear in the united
states that uh
you know people who are not white and
not men make
much less money for doing the same job
and this just isn't true
but when you factor in education
experience
all these sorts of things hours worked
uh
those pay gaps disappear in the civil
service though you actually can sort of
compare these things
and so shocking because it up ends the
usual
ideology we're being fed the white guy
is being being paid less than the black
lady he absolutely should
sue for this i do not think that we
ought to have a politics
that is rooted primarily around race or
primarily around
sex but that's what the left is pushing
and if the left
if that is the dominant regime then
that dread awful worst sort of
individual you could possibly imagine
the straight white male now with
gender ideology i guess you'd have to
say that straight white male who knows
that he's a male
has to push back against injustice
the system broadly is rife with
injustice and of course
we need to push back against that
injustice i think a lot of people would
not want to do this
well first of all this guy here is
making a ton of money so he's really got
nothing to complain about
and i think a lot of white guys don't
want to be accused of being racist so
they'd say i'll just i'll let it go okay
these other people are being paid more
because they're race and sex okay that's
fine i don't whatever it's all
no big deal but it is a big deal it's
wrong for everybody
you know we often hear from the left
racism is a problem for everybody
injustice for anybody is an injustice
for everybody well yeah in a way that's
true
if you've got an unjust system you it is
your obligation
to push back against that sort of thing
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you